dramatische kriegstage damit willkommen
zurück bei bild live und der
bundeskanzler äußert sich gerade er hat
das einsatzführungskommando der
bundeswehr in potsdam gerade besucht das
sind seine worte die nato und ihre
mitgliedstaaten sich nicht an dem krieg
beteiligen und gleichzeitig tun wer aber
alles mit unseren möglichkeiten um dazu
beizutragen dass eine entwicklung in der
ukraine möglich ist die für die menschen
mit
einem waffenstillstand verbunden ist und
auch den abzug der truppen die bilder
die wir jetzt schon sehen von den
zerstörungen sind schrecklich genug da
brauchen wir nicht noch viele weitere
dazu und deshalb ist es so wichtig dass
wir gesagt haben wir arbeiten mit
unseren politischen möglichkeiten was
sanktionen betrifft die wir lange vorher
angekündigt haben für den fall einer
militärischen invasion und ansonsten
nutzen wir jeden spielraum um auf
diplomatischen wege ein ende dieser
kampfhandlungen zu bewirken wie gesagt
nicht anders dieses besuches aber gut
dass ich heute hier sein konnte und die
arbeit hier
betrachten und verstehen könnte wie sie
geleistet wird noch mal ein großer dank
an die bundeswehr und die soldatinnen
und soldaten
es ist ganz wichtig dass wir einen
kühlen kopf bewahren dass wir sie klar
und entschlossen sind und vorsichtig
bleiben denn das ist ja unsere aufgabe
dass es keine ausweitung dieses
konfliktes über den über die ukraine
hinaus gibt und das ist auch die
gemeinsame haltung von uns allen und
deshalb sind wir mit dieser besonnenheit
alle gemeinsam unterwegs und das ist
auch richtig so
vielleicht noch keine situation
entstehen
der andere punkt kommen werden der
andere braucht in der regierung damit zu
verstehen wäre weiß dass ich ihr pc das
noch ein könig gerufen
es ist für uns völlig klar dass es keine
militärische
beteiligung der nato an diesem konflikt
geben wird das werden wir ausschließen
mit all dem was wir machen das ist auch
unsere aufgabe das zu tun was wir tun
ist dafür zu sorgen dass wir gemeinsam
sicherstellen dass niemand das nato
territorium angreift und deshalb haben
wir unsere gemeinsamen bemühungen an der
grenze von den baltischen staaten
angefangen über polen die slowakei
ungarn rumänien und bulgarien verstärkt
aber die sind rein defensiv und sie
bleiben auf dem territorium der nato das
was wir bewirken können um die
kriegshandlungen in der ukraine zu
beenden können wir nur durch diese
beiden starken handlungsfelder bewirken
die wir haben nämlich einerseits die
konsequente umsetzung der lange
vorbereiteten sanktionen die jetzt ja
auch ihre heftigen wirkung bereits auf
die ökonomischen
entwicklungsmöglichkeiten russlands
haben und gleichzeitig die ständige
ununterbrochene bemühungen dafür zu
sorgen dass es nicht
weitergeht mit diesem krieg dass er
beendet wird und dass die möglichkeit
einer gemeinsamen eines gemeinsamen
ausweg aus dieser krise versucht wird
obwohl es jetzt schon so weit gekommen
ist
zunächst mal ist es wichtig dass wir
sofort uns informiert haben über die
situation bei dem atomkraftwerk und der
anlage dort das geht ja auch mehrere
reaktoren die dort sind teilweise in
betrieb teilweise nicht wir haben
gemessen mit anderen zusammen uns
ausgetauscht über die gefahr des
auftretens radioaktiver strahlung und
all dem was damit verbunden ist wir
haben uns informiert über die situation
vor ort konkret wo jetzt das feuer
ausgebrochen ist ich habe auch in der
nacht kontakt gehabt zu präsident selenz
geht er mich angerufen hat und wir haben
sofort mit all unseren partnern die
notwendigen dinge auf den weg gebracht
um die situation zu verstehen und
deshalb ist es so dass wir gegen
bertlich jedenfalls wissen dass all
diese gefahren sich nicht realisiert
haben sondern es bei dem brand in einem
verwaltungsgebäude geblieben ist
trotzdem sind wir natürlich immer
vorbereitet auf eine situation in der es
doch zu einer beim austritt von
radioaktiven elementen kommen kann aber
das ist jetzt eben nicht passiert es
zeigt aber wie gefährlich die situation
ist kriege führen immer dazu dass
zerstörungen angerichtet werden wo sie
vielleicht auch keine der kriegsparteien
wirklich vorhat aber die trotzdem ihre
schrecklichen auswirkungen haben können
und deshalb ist es wichtig dass man
sofort alles dafür tut solche
eskalationen zu vermeiden auch in diesem
fall ist das geschehen und das ist das
was ich ihnen gern berichten kann
europa mit seinen über 400 millionen
einwohnern seinen 27 mitgliedstaaten hat
sich entschieden solidarisch das zu tun
was für die aufnahme von flüchtlingen
erforderlich ist wir haben eine
unbürokratische regelung in der eu
gefunden zur aufnahme von flüchtlingen
und natürlich haben alle länder jetzt
sich angefangen darauf vorzubereiten
dass sie die flüchtlinge die bei ihnen
ankommen aufnehmen können und dass das
auch solidarisch untereinander getragen
wird auch deutschland macht das die
bundesinnenministerium phaser ist
intensiv dabei zusammen mit den ländern
in deutschland die notwendigen
vorbereitungen zu treffen
schönen dank
das war also der bundeskanzler olaf
scholz nach seinem truppenbesuch beim
einsatzführungskommando der bundeswehr
in potsdam und er hat dort noch einmal
ganz klar ein nato eingriff in diesen
aktuellen krieg in der ukraine
ausgeschlossen ganz klar aber das ist
inzwischen der riesen diskussion hier in
deutschland wie lange können wie lange
dürfen und wie lange wollen wir hier
beim töten in der ukraine noch zuschauer
cdu chef friedrich merz schliesst eine
direkte verwicklung der nato in
russlands angriffskrieg nämlich
mittlerweile nicht mehr aus er hatte
einem radiointerview heute gegeben bei
ndr info und das sagt ja die angriffe
und die art und weise wie dieser krieg
geführt wird die nehmen formen an die
zum nachdenken zwingen und dann kommt ja
ein ganz entscheidender satz er sagt
nämlich es kann eine situation geben in
der dann auch die nato entscheidungen
treffen muss um putin zu stoppen und
dann sagt er weiter wenn sich so etwas
wiederholen sollte wenn möglicherweise
sogar die reaktorblöcke getroffen werden
sollten dann sind wir unmittelbar
bedroht von den auswirkungen dieses
krieges riesen debatte mittlerweile in
deutschland also um eben doch einen
möglichen nato eingriff in diesen
ukraine krieg